journalism is under attack
like never before no hustle treaty gas
fire you have to have the fence
beautiful but tragic because people are
doubting everything
you're the only way of telling their
story how would you describe this
outbreak something like an apocalypse
you're going to be
really tired you're going to be really
scared it's too dangerous
anyone who says they're not scared is
life anything can happen
did you get here i sometimes wonder how
have we managed to get out of this being
killed
we do genuinely believe in what we do
he's clearly marching press
to show the truth wow this is absolutely
unbelievable to uncover
on injustice this is the result of
ethnic cleansing i don't think any
journalist wants anything more than that
i'm alex crawford i'm stuart ramsey and
this is hot spots
[Music]
[Applause]
coming up on hot spots this is flat
my team is in kenya investigating the
plastic pollution in the waters of
africa
our whole industry is going to die we've
just scrapped the surface there's still
loads out there
the wind is up it's really dangerous and
i'm in the amazon where fires are
destroying the landscape and livelihoods
with devastating effects
they're going to need reinforcements
hopelessly these guys five of them
can't take on this number of fires
it was an island of plastic oh my god
that's disgusting
it's joking life
we understand you're manufacturing
illegal plastic bags
what is it we're waiting for it's a
dying leak
so skye's been running this ocean rescue
campaign for many years now
examining the level of plastic pollution
in oceans
and we thought well as rivers flow into
oceans
what's happening to the rivers
looking at how fresh water in africa was
affected by
microplastics tiny bits of plastic
fragments of plastic
getting into the water and then getting
into fish and the food chain it was a
huge
undertaking the whole project many
different countries involved we set out
to find out
how much plastic there was in the
longest
river in the world the river nile and
one of the countries that we focused on
was kenya
africa is just an incredibly visual
feast of wildlife and fantastic scenery
to film
at any time
in particular is rich in
color and there's beauty everywhere you
point your camera
this was my first time actually
discovering the heart of africa
it's just a beautiful place to work
late victoria is one of the big wonders
of africa is the largest freshwater lake
in africa and it is huge
it's an amazing place
[Music]
we knew plastic pollution was a real
issue there
the aim was to in some ways expose this
sort of
underbelly of the nasty side
of plastic what you're seeing everywhere
is disposable nappies sunny pads
bottles condoms all sorts of things
lake victoria is one of the main sources
of the river nile and everything that
ends up in lake victoria
ends up being fed into the river nile
and it's not very obvious at the
beginning because
you just don't see it all you see is
lots of water and lots of
foliage along the river banks plastic is
the number one problem around this place
especially the bottles
what's this
yeah within minutes we've got
loads and loads of of plastic
it's a small tributary leading to lake
victoria and it was just clogged with
plastic
you haven't got to go very far to gather
boatloads of this stuff and it just gets
washed out and sinks and
breaks apart and it's just all hidden
and there's tons and tons of it
this is just a tiny portion of what
we've picked out look all this
partially disintegrated plastic bags
there's old nappies there's
bottles look at all these bottles in
what about
20 minutes or so and actually we've just
scraped the surface there's still loads
out there
in lake victoria basically everyone who
lives around the shores
that's millions of people they rely on
fish and
what we were hearing was that those
supplies of fish are dwindling in a
really severe manner
and plastic is one of the major causes
for that
fishing crews have to go out all night
so the sort of things we're slightly
concerned about are
obviously crocodiles hippos everything's
a bit more dangerous at night
we've just no idea what we're gonna see
really if we're gonna see many
boats if the camera can pick them up
because it's sort of
pitch black here keep uh the water clean
tom
emboya was basically a local hero
he's been fishing since he was a boy
he's
born and brought up around that area
he's turned into
an environmental warrior because from
very early on
he realized there were big changes
happening right in front of him it's
another boat
there we've got a mission
yeah it's not quite as simple as just
drifting out to sea
we were just heading off into the middle
of this lake on this slightly rickety
fishing boat fast speed
of the amble okay be prepared
fishermen have these lights that float
above the surface
the fish has been attracted
to that light
they're all going out in small numbers
in these little canoe boats
spreading a huge net
and then they pull it in by hand really
exhausting physical work
you were expecting you know tons of fish
to be holed up but actually what they
bought out was pathetic
is that considered a good hall or a
little hole
very poor hog the whole of fish they are
catching is getting
less and less over time this is
really really poor and pathetic so
i purely blame it on plastics tom was
sounding the alarm bell
you can see plastic very obvious look at
that that's plastic
in the middle of nowhere in those areas
along those
poor coastal regions fishing will be
the livelihood that sustains
whole communities literally millions of
people
plastic is overwhelming the fish
my greatest fear is that a whole
industry
is going to die and with it quite a
number of people because
without money no life without food no
life
and that's the saddest that i feel about
this lake
he's not just concerned about how
small the fish are on how much fewer
fish there are he's concerned about the
health because if the fish
are ingesting plastic sooner or later
that's going to come home
to roost the suggestion is that by
eating
a fish which may have contained
fragments of plastic
then as then getting into the human food
chain or other predators are consuming
it and then
it continues it's a dying lake
if nothing is done about it from now
the fisherman had been out all night so
it was very early in the morning
the place was already thronging with
people
everyone was crowded around trying to
get the best deal
bartering for how much and who gets the
best biggest fish here or a little small
right here
sifting through huge buckets of fish
that have just been
brought in from lake victoria was this a
good catch for them
for us it looked like a huge amount of
fish that was being brought in
but you know we were being told this
isn't much fish this isn't going to be
enough to
to earn enough money 2 000 between four
people
[Music]
tom had told us that underneath
lake victoria was a bed of plastic it
was
a plastic island and the only way of
testing that
was to go down and see if there was
plastic
on the bottom of lake victoria
lake victoria is considered one of the
most dangerous bodies of water
in the world based on the number of
people who've died in it
it's got hippos which are considered
very dangerous they uh apparently kill
more people
than other predators do it's got
crocodiles
it's got really high levels of at least
three dangerous metals so
there were quite a lot of considerations
about getting into that water
we met up with ryla whose normal day job
was
searching for dead bodies
he will die if someone's gone missing
and try and find the body
that's what he does he's a body
collector
raila exuded security and confidence he
clearly knew his way around the waters
so we knew that there were hippos down
the corner we knew that the place was
filled with
no crocodiles right now but he picked
the spot
and said this will be fine
and over the side she went uh down to
try and get some plastic from the bottom
of the lake victoria
oh it is completely black down there
can't see a thing i couldn't even see
his hands
it was like swimming in black the small
underwater camera that we gave
ryla was useless it was so murky
oh my god that's disgusting i think it's
another nappy
every time we went in we pulled out
stuff
well that's what you don't that's what
the fish are up against
you don't even have to move far because
we told you that this is going to be
plastic island
it was revolting oh it's just a tip down
there
it's a bed of plastic under
the water and there's soil on top of it
it's already buried
let's try that
honestly each time without any
problem i was pulling out masses amount
and we were loading the boat with it
lapis
that's for ogali and all of it
disgusting
industrial waste chemical waste
personal waste everything you can think
of pretty much
seemed to be at the bottom of that lake
this is a 70 000 square kilometer
lake i can't imagine
how much plastic is lying at the bottom
of this huge lake
which we don't know about just yet
the thing is on the top of the lake you
can't see anything and then
just beneath there's all this toxic
waste i think tom was right it was an
island of of plastic
everywhere you walk if you look down
here it's all
plastic look at that
those are tumblers yeah those are
strodes
when it rains finds its way into the
water bodies
consumers kenya's third largest city and
everywhere you look has some evidence of
plastic still
hydrophilic it's just a monumental
problem
trying to get rid of it
[Music]
kenya itself has introduced one of the
toughest
laws against single-use plastic in the
world
in 2017 it outlawed single-use plastic
the plastic bags are a start but a start
but it's not everything virtually every
stall
sells these replacements for plastic
which are
meant to be more environmentally
friendly and are
biodegradable so they have that and
that's
very difficult to change people's
perception of
the use of plastic but it's better than
the normal plastic
bags kenya had actually made huge
strides
and instituted very tough
penalties for using for manufacturing
for producing or for selling single-use
plastics particularly plastic bags
[Music]
the problem with instituting a ban
against
plastic bags is that it opens up a whole
avenue
where people can try and make money
through the black market
we had no idea how many manufacturers
were producing plastic bags
illegally in kenya but we knew they were
so we wanted to get evidence
of these actual manufacturers these
producers
of these illegal plastic bags
working in kenya is monumentally
difficult
certain countries are just incredibly
difficult for
independent journalists to operate you
will find corruption in almost
every level
it is very easy to get hoodwinked
it was incredibly difficult to find the
actual
source of the manufacturing of these
plastic bags
we followed false lead after false lead
we were led down
lord knows how many dead ends what's
going on
these things are pretty frustrating what
is it we're waiting for
we met with people who said that they
could lead us to the illegal
manufacturers how they were
working at night in illegal factories
because they couldn't operate during the
day so we did a number of different
night time stakeouts our investigations
have shown there are a number of
businesses in nairobi manufacturing
illegal plastic bags we've had a tip-off
and we're heading off to this one
particular outfit
which we understand is making tens of
thousands of bags
every week
we were chasing our tails it was really
frustrating
no it's going on they're producing this
stuff but
they were being tipped off
come on quickly we identified this
factory which was meant to be
making illegal plastic bags alex
crawford from sky news
we understand you're manufacturing
illegal plastic bags here
we burst in we understood that you're
manufacturing illegal plastic bags here
we are not making plastic bags
they just make fights it became
apparent that it wasn't what it was sold
to us
they weren't making any plastic bags at
all apparently they used to make plastic
bags way back before the ban
all of those plastic bags there where
did they come from
we buy material we had to go and say i'm
sorry
we made a mistake well thank you very
much for letting us in
well it was hugely embarrassing actually
strong place but that was just a part of
the
the slog to get that story we were so
close
a lot of times so we just had to keep
pushing and trying and trying you feel
you haven't got that full story that you
can tell to people
until you've got the evidence at both
ends
the head of kenya's national environment
agency
is njoki makuri
and in jockey is a
kick-ass woman this this is the raw
material
this is what they use for the box
she is in no doubt one of the most
impressive women i've come across
where do you get this from no nonsense
great sense of humor what do you do here
these windscreens here
not taking any [ __ ] from anyone you
should be very daring if we will
continue to produce after this
the national environment management
authority is a big
agency in kenya can you imagine
a woman in an incredibly male
dominated part of the world
in an incredibly male dominated
profession
getting to the top of that and running
it
this is bad smelly
we might we might have to close it down
here
do things right
it becomes very difficult to enforce
because they're cause they tape to the
table yeah they tip them off she was
facing
levels that you cannot even imagine of
police corruption
so what happens is that we are forced to
do the raids in a very discreet way
we don't actually tell them where we are
going most of the time is that if they
get to know that we are we want to raid
a place they will
definitely inform the people
time and time again when we were with
her we'd arrive and
they'd already been told that nema was
on their way
and they'd scarfed they weren't sure
when they turned up whether they'd be
attacked
knifed shot punched spat at
that happens especially with the markets
where we have
all these small traders that are using
the bugs and they are sold
in the riskiest places in this town you
know places that you can't just walk
and buy and it's like a cartel it's like
a network
like a place like this when we are
coming to the operation we just come in
the rest
let's go and see what's going on
they have no idea what dangers they were
going to face when they set out
and yet her and her team were
so committed it's very frustrating
but we'll keep pushing you see the team
is young all of us
you've got many
they did anything to try and track down
these
plastic bag gangs there are a lot of
plastic bags here
they're faced with being always a few
steps behind the bad guys
the good thing about these raids is that
they're very high profile
and they're intended to be so that
everyone around gets the
message that plastic bags are not
allowed and will not be put up with
to be honest i'm pretty pessimistic
about plastic pollution in africa
every stretch of water every lake was
clogged with plastic of some description
and it's hard to see how that can be
undone
it's easy to get overwhelmed by how bad
things are
and how big the problem is
plastic is everywhere but developing
nations i'd like to think they
have a chance to develop in an
ecological way and
to have a better non-plastic future
when you meet individuals like tom
and jockey who are
real fighters and real devotees
committed
to the cause when you see them faced
with
all of these challenges and they're
still continuing
and if they're not giving up and they
feel they're
somehow making a difference then
honestly the rest of the
world shouldn't be giving up either
because
the alternative is death by plastic
up next in front of us was this
incredibly fast moving
sheet of fire they're going to try and
go ashore and see how injured it is
never in my wildest dreams did i think i
was going to get as close as i did
the most important story future
generations of journalists will work on
is the environment
so so hot within seconds it was at my
legs
fires they don't just destroy trees they
destroy habitats
they've just found the jaguar
now the leaders of the g7 nations are
being urged to put the amazon rainforest
top of their agenda when they meet
tomorrow
france's president emmanuel macron is
leading the calls and has declared the
forest bars raging through the amazon
an international crisis 2019
saw the worst increase in fires in the
amazon
for decades all the indicators were that
these fires
were up and running again and yet it
wasn't really being reported
the amazon fires are sometimes started
by humans
because of ranching and clearing the
forest to make ranches
but also because the temperature is
increasing so much
the rainforest shouldn't go on fire it's
just too wet
if it's getting hotter and hotter then
it is going on fire
and is being destroyed forever
the amazon being on fire is in itself an
incredibly important story
but to be completely denied made it
slightly different as a story
they were saying it simply wasn't true
and we wanted to prove them wrong
everyone says it and so for me to say it
again
you know it just seems like empty words
but the environment and the climate is
one of the most important stories
of my generation of generations to come
i think
they're the most important stories we do
are none
brazil was a big country and you know
we had to do a lot of traveling to get
to the amazon
we obviously flew from the uk to south
parallel then we had to fly
internally it's difficult to get into
your mind
just how massive it is you know
long flights on jets and you've hardly
moved anywhere
on the map i am um
sending our driver and and car
information to the news desk
this is all going by road yeah and then
we're gonna charter
so that we can get a view of the fires
from the air
and then your work begins
we had a small aircraft that we were
going to take to get to south felix de
jingo which is
it was about a 10 or 12 hour drive from
where we were
the view is quite staggering perhaps
more than anything
staggering because of the amount of
rainforest that's been cut down
staggering amount of farms that you see
literally as far as the eye can see
which should not be there
and then staggering because of the trees
just basically breaking out on fire
marcia is a trusted friend and she's a
fantastic journalist in her own right we
have a very
similar idea of how to communicate and
how to produce
so all these areas that's very hard to
concentrate you
it was impressive and it was sad at the
same time
further today i had a great little
adventure because the pilot let me uh
fly the plane hasn't like heard this
like you know shuffling about up front
and i was like what and then you know
stuart turned around
at that point what are you going to do
i did look back and stuart was looking a
bit green around the guilds i didn't
feel very good about it at all
to be frank as we sort of started um
i don't i'm sure the word is i wouldn't
say dive but drifting to the left and
right
um was quite upsetting
cameraman pilot you know
[Music]
brilliant we wanted to travel to south
felix to jingle because
it was the base location of the
firefighters
who were fighting fires in the amazon
rainforest
for that particular state she's geared
back
martial had said there's only five and
will i yeah okay you know
really it's like you know but maybe five
in one group or five and one section
she's like no there are five
five you know fighting fires in an area
we worked out to be larger than scotland
i'm not so certain if it does indicate a
lack of real seriousness
and uh government commitment to fighting
the
fires in the amazon because the fire
brigade
operate out of a crash
their gear and their one truck is parked
up
and of course all their fireman's
clothes and socks and pants
drying in the sun etc and it looked
pretty miserable
professional firemen they're not from
the region they've been brought in
to tackle these so-called non-fires
and their job is i think it's simply
hopeless
[Applause]
[Music]
i think we must have driven for five or
six hours
and sure enough in the distance you
could see smoke
we got near and near and we could see
that this was a big big blaze
and they pulled over came out with all
their gear on
and we were then right at it
the tools the firemen had to fight these
fires were frankly
pathetic they had fire beaters
and they had a couple of these water
packs that go on their back
with a sort of a pump attachment at the
front like something you would use in
your garden
and that was it
the cows were running and the firemen
were trying to get them away from the
fire so they would be protected and i
was filming something else
let's do it let's do it over here
he's about to miss a brilliant sticker
richard needs to keep an eye on this guy
he's trying to force the cattle out
dominique seems to particularly want
that that shot
when we know the fires are driven by
deforestation which is driven by cattle
farming i just thought what a
perfect sort of example of those all
those things in one she made it fairly
clear that um
she wasn't that impressed but impressed
with me at the time
and i think i made my uh my opinion
known
i spent the next sort of half hour
sprinting up and down these hills trying
to
to make up for it i'm going
[Music]
this guy had provided us with this kind
of fireman sound outfits
big thick heavy cotton on top of your
normal clothes
and in that heat and remember we had
only been in country a couple of days so
there'd been no
opportunity to acclimatise at all
and i couldn't get any air in whatsoever
you take that off and suddenly you're
right in the smoke
complete i got a lung full of smoke and
that clearly affected me
and so i started to really overheat and
struggle to breathe
i might need a minute
and um i have to admit there are a
couple of you know
sharp moments with my colleagues
okay i'm very sorry with everyone clean
getting out of my way so i can get the
shot that everybody wants
my hands were tingling my peripheral
vision had started to go a little bit
foggy
you start making really bad decisions
because you're exhausted
i was well aware that this was happening
to me and also the fact that you start
getting snappy with people around you
that is one of the telltale signs of
heat exhaustion
we had to take a little time out a
little break there to let me recover and
get my breath back
[Music]
there is a kind of unseen danger about
fires because
they move so rapidly and they can change
directions
of course the closer you get the more
you actually see the colors of the fires
the
red orange flames then everywhere
you look just thick thick black smog
from all the smoke
in front of us was this incredibly fast
moving
sheet of fire that would move at the
speed of the wind
within seconds it was you know virtually
at my legs
just have to keep watching you can't
lose concentration
it's hot man the flames catch up on you
really really quickly
i still think it's coming at us really
fast now it's not out of control but
if we're drawing it's so so hot nhs
burning out the trade you can see
there's
not see behind but this huge forest out
there as well
the wind is off it's really dangerous
really really dangerous
does this happen often is this most
years
[Music]
yes
it was his land and he explained that
the fire had started about three or four
days before
that he and the guys that he employed
had been attempting to control the fire
but each time they got
it under control or at least stopped its
spread
and as soon as the temperatures got
going again it would flare up
the professionalism of the farm is
remarkable they're taking on these fires
just trying to beat them down and they
are quite
impressive and they're quite effective
they can actually stop the fires
spreading through just pure physical
hard work
but as soon as the winds get up as soon
as the temperature rises
these fires just start again
you wonder what is the point
[Music]
it's really difficult to explain to
anybody
just how vast the amazon is
it's huge and these trees that are
centuries old are so
high and so tall it's impossible to get
a sense of scale from the ground
a drone is an absolutely essential tool
in that environment
as soon as it went up you know it was
mind-blowing
i'd go as far as saying they were you
know some of the most
impactful pictures that i've ever shot
i knew they were really good i knew they
were really powerful
bringing the drone back
it basically dropped out of the sky and
we lost the drone
i was gutted because i knew what was on
there i was absolutely devastated
we searched for the drone we couldn't
find the drone
i i didn't sleep much that night i was
absolutely
devastated about those pictures being
out there somewhere
the next day we were going back to the
same area and while richie and stuart
went off to film a bit more with the
firefighters in a different area of the
forest
marty and i went to where we were the
previous evening
while we were searching for the drone we
came across
this flattened piece of plastic metal
which was gray white the same color as
the drone but i took a picture of it
in case we didn't find the drone
you know i come out of the trees and i'm
full of hope and expectation
i thought i'm just going to play a
little joke on ritchie
and marcia shows me a photo of this
thing that was sort of drone shaped but
completely melted on the ground i was i
you know
i was almost in tears yeah tada showed
him the drone
and there was darren the drone and uh
all safe and well and so were the
pictures and i i just can't explain the
relief
happy richie
i'm ecstatic i am honestly very relieved
my kids called him darren when i first
got him and so um
so that's darren he's been ever since
but once you attach a name to something
knowing that
darren was out there on his own in the
amazon all night you know you you're
like it was it was it was a
it was a tough one i was worried about
him i felt happy that i found the drone
because i felt like
it was like a little makeup present over
the cattle
well the firemen they're gonna need
reinforcements this is hopeless there's
ten fires that we've seen in there and
then there's this one
absolutely vast whole side of a mountain
is gone it's on fire on the other side
there's just not enough fire power here
these guys five of them
can't take on this number of fires it's
uh it's incredible
we're going to go back to sao paulo and
homer we've had a bit of a change of
plan
we really thought that that was probably
the end of our trip and we were going to
slowly make our way back to
sao paulo to then head back to the to
the uk or maybe even onwards
this uh largest wetlands in the world
sort of in the center of brazil so it's
not part of the amazon it's its own
thing but it's on fire lots of animals
we feel if we've come this far we may as
well go and do that story as well
it's another huge journey and long drive
to get to the panthen
i think up whole trip was about 10 hours
and then we've got
a flight to brasilia and then a flight
from brasilia onwards to our next
destination
it's huge this place is huge
last time i was here of course i was
getting on my own plane
the fires had been going for a while but
this was now much more about trying to
look towards rebuilding and to looking
after animals that have been heard
we saw the volume of animals that were
being brought in i mean we were there
for about half an hour or 40 minutes
and the door kept opening with a new
animal that had been injured
and finally a baby otter
show stealer of all show stealers
[Music]
this is possibly the cutest animal
you'll ever see
[Music]
we headed off on a boat with these vets
to try and look for
jaguars over the previous couple of days
they had seen
a wounded jaguar down needless water's
edge
we headed off in this incredible smoky
atmosphere
jaguars are one of the most elusive
creatures on earth and and frankly
in in the back of my mind i never
thought we were going to see one in a
month and some days
they were worried that if there were too
many boats and people around that the
jaguar would get spooked and go deeper
into the forest
they wanted to dart it and then examine
it
so we stayed back for a little while and
waited for the right moment
they've just found the jaguar we're
heading upriver to see if we can catch
up with the vets they're going to try
and
go ashore and see how injured it is
never in my wildest dreams did i think i
was going to get as close as i did
this jaguar probably eight foot tailed
her nose
was lying there you know growling
grunting
my camera was sort of eight inches from
his nose
and just hairs were up on the back of my
neck and
magnificent creature
the good news is that january actually
been hunting
and uh is feeding one of the plans was
maybe
to have to remove him but they don't
have to so he's going to be given
medicine
and then eventually he'll come around
we're going to leave him and he's going
to be alive and
fine
they then gave it antidote everybody
lifted it up and moved it into the
forest
they didn't want it when it was drowsy
accidentally walking into the river and
getting itself into trouble
that's when stuart and i and some of the
vets and team went back to the boat
just in case it woke up quicker than
they thought while richie stayed with
the vets
i was statue like
filming this incredible creature slowly
waking up and
becoming more lucid and getting itself
[Music]
together
wow that was amazing
he started to wake up
looking right right at me as us
it's just amazing
[Music]
fires they don't just destroy trees
they destroy habitats
[Music]
how does it look since the last time you
hit
it's devastation scenario
i don't know how much the the nature can
restore itself you know for how long
i was really deeply affected by what i
saw in the amazon
i think it's a tragedy and i don't think
the international community is doing
enough
i don't want to be looking my grandkids
in the eye one day and telling them that
we didn't do anything
what happens to climate world is by far
the most important story that we will
ever
work on now more than ever
the story of climate change of what we
as humans are doing to the world around
us
is the responsibility of all of us to
tell there will be wars over water
there will be wars about development
there will be wars about
resources uh declining because of the
environment
and it's slow drift towards what looks
like the tipping point
where you just simply can't save places
like
the amazon
or even the panda now
[Music]
next time on hotspots thank you for
brazil
i return to brazil as kovid19 overwhelms
the country
and they simply refuse to accept
anything needs to be changed at all
we are here to support our president
because our president he's really tough
really strong
welcome to america and my team are in
texas
at the heart of the american virus
pandemic world number one is a topic
virus number two is stupidity
i couldn't believe exactly what she was
saying you better believe i'm angry
i'm thicker this [ __ ] until then you can
find us on twitter
at alex crawford's guy and at ramsey
style
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
oh